well despite the winds we had earlier
today causing a lot of delays at the
airport a special flight was right on
time this afternoon as certain flights
from germany resumed service madison
kimbrough was there and has reaction
from international travelers
a lot of excitement inside of terminal 3
this afternoon as international
travelers made their way from frankfurt
germany
it's great to be out and about again
isn't it
it's so yeah it's been two years of sort
of like not going anywhere harry reid
international has welcomed munich
germany and zurich switzerland into las
vegas both out of edelweiss and
eurowing's discover airlines travel from
frankfurt germany started back up in
march with condor airlines and now
eurowings discover from frankfort
returned monday evening for the first
time since before the pandemic and for
the majority of passengers it's their
first time in las vegas zara wills
arrived on the frankfurt flight and said
it's extra special visiting vegas for
the first time because she's here to
attend her brother's wedding during the
first two
lockdown stints it was getting like
touch-and-go as to whether or not they'd
be able to do it out here
so it's really exciting to be able to do
it now we're going to do a lot of stuff
that's been planned by them and his
fiance's family's out here as well so
it's going to be a lot of family time
and just exploring eurowings discover
flights operate between las vegas to
frankfurt four times a week and flights
between las vegas and munich twice a
week the fact that the people that come
from overseas stay longer spend more is
not something that we can overlook today
really is the culmination 24 months
later we've come full circle and to
welcome these flights back from germany
from switzerland that's a phenomenal
achievement and jones also says that
flights from korea could be their next
venture next month there will be nonstop
service into las vegas from 17 different
international destinations reporting
inside of harry reid international
airport madison kimbrough live local now